you see in Rappaport he's got a busy
morning NFL Network reporter and kind
enough to join us all right let's recap
the Garoppolo trade when was this
started when did they light the fuse on
this and how did it get done yesterday
actually yesterday morning I mean this
is one where you know the Patriots have
been adamant really since forever on
since last offseason that they did not
want to trade Jimmy Garoppolo they never
took him off the table they never said
what I consider offers they just never
did come anywhere close to them I know
the Browns made an offer for a two and
change during the draft that they just
didn't even really think about but then
yesterday you know when the 49ers called
there were a couple reasons to consider
this one first of all they already got
about eight games out of Garoppolo
that's eight games of insurance for Tom
Brady who they basically now realize is
going to play into his forties deep into
his 40s and that confidence really
helped them make this trade so I think
that was that was one thing and then you
know you get a second-round pick back
it's probably going to be a 33 or 34 in
exchange for a quarterback who's played
two games for the I feel like for both
sides it's a pretty good deal yeah but I
wondered if they use they turn around
and use that second-round pick today and
try to get some defensive help because I
don't know the Patriots even with Tom
Brady can win the Super Bowl this year
with that defense your thoughts they are
looking for some defensive help that is
true my understanding is it hasn't
reached the point where they're looking
for someone who would cost them a second
round or like I think it'd be more like
kind of late fifth six night guys mmm I
would expect some defensive line depth
if they can do it I haven't gotten the
sense they're really looking to add like
blockbuster guys but they definitely are
trying to add some some defensive health
no doubt about it
did we over rate or over value Jimmy
Garoppolo because it feels like the
Patriots didn't get anything great in
return and maybe I you know that it felt
like Rob Lowe was that played himself
into maybe the value of a first-round
pick why was he not a first-round pick
talent
well there's a couple reasons first of
all he only played two games you know he
was supposed to play four and got
injured so the what everyone is going
off of his pre-season which we've seen
people thrive in the preseason and
obviously not so much to the regular
season he only played two games so I
think that that is one thing like what
do you what are you actually getting you
can like the player you can like the
scouting they did on him when he was
coming out but everyone likes the
players they Scout
especially their own picks so you don't
really know there is that uncertainty
the other thing is he's going to get a
contract extension at some point so when
you trade for a player who has yet to
have an extension then you don't get as
much for him because the team knows our
what we're trading for him and then
we're gonna give next amount of dollars
to him in a contract ascent so it always
brings always significantly brings the
price down and look I mean the Patriots
you know probably could have had a
better offer for Cleveland but they
chose to make this move really at the
last possible time they could have
gotten anything legitimate for him and
they didn't want to franchise in the
offseason I know that does Belichick
have a problem with dealing with the
Browns III know that they traded Collins
there but is there anything left over
any residue from Belichick and his his
dealings in his stay in Cleveland I'm
sure I mean you know I got if I don't
think he's gonna be dressing is his
grandchild in Jets gear and I don't
think he'll be dressing his grandchild
in Browns gear like so I mean you know
is he gonna hope the Browns win every
week and go 16 - no I'm just gonna guess
probably not but the Patriots in a lot
of ways don't care they only do what is
best for them so them not taking the
Browns deal this past offseason wasn't
about the Browns it was about that was
their insurance in case Tom Brady wasn't
able to do it I mean no one first saw
Peyton Manning falling off looks like he
did in the last year
so whenever Tom Brady goes the wrong way
it's gonna be a surprise to everyone
because a quarterback is great until he
isn't
you know Tony Romo knew that I think he
knew which direction he was going
to hang it up you know so the Patriots
didn't do the Browns deal I believe so
they could get a half a year of
insurance out of Jimmy Garoppolo and I
think that was worth you see in
Rappaport NFL Network insider the Eagles
got Jay a jockey tell us about that deal
yeah and there's definitely been some
frustration with Adam GaSe in several
was offensive players over the last
couple weeks a Jahi in particular I know
they didn't really see eye to eye and
I'm not surprised he's gone it's still
blockbuster trade anything for the
Eagles they get a very very good
franchise running back who's gonna split
carries with like Eric 1 and probably
going to be the main guy next year and
for the Dolphins they get a fresh start
they get him to another team and they
get to make do with what they have
Damian Williams Kenyan Drake some of
those guys any deal that you see
possibly happening by the 4:00 p.m.
Eastern trade deadline yeah I think
there's a couple of big names to keep an
eye on Eric Ebron but the Lions is
certainly one ago he was drawing some
interest last week and and will continue
to draw some interest to I Hilton is a
name that has been discussed a lot
another couple said had made it known
that a lot of their guys are available
for the right price as you would with
any team that's you know that's in the
place where they are based on wins and
losses
Vontae Davis I know there's one that
they discussed with several other teams
I'm not sure how much of a market that
really is you know those are sort of the
we've already gotten a couple of the big
ones off the table Dwayne brown goes I
don't see Cordy Glen going anywhere
we've gotten some big ones off the table
already I know you're busy I appreciate
you joining us in Thank You Carmen
that's Ian Rapoport NFL Network insider
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]